we are told we want to solve the
following equation that the negative
natural log of 2x is equal to 2 times
the absolute value of x minus 4
all of that minus 7. one of the
solutions is x is equal to 0.5
find the other solution they say hint
use a graphing calculator and round your
answer to the nearest tenth so pause
this video and have a go at this if if
you like and then we'll work on this
together and i encourage you to have a
go on it
go at it
all right now let's work on this
together now the key here is to realize
that we might be able to solve this by
graphing or at least approximate the
solutions to this by graphing and the
way we do that is if we have an equation
especially a hairy equation like this in
one variable we can set y equal to the
left and then set y equal to the right
and then graph each of those functions
and then think about where they
intersect because they'll intersect at
an x value that gives us the same y
value and that means that the two sides
are the same so what do i mean by that
well we could set y is equal to the
negative natural log of 2x so we could
have one
equation or one function like that
and then we could have another equation
or a function that y is equal to 2 times
the absolute value of x minus 4
minus 7. and let's see where they
intersect and the x values where they
intersect those are going to be
solutions to that
so i'm going to use desmos as my
graphing calculator
so let's type in the two sides so first
i'll do the left side so if y is equal
to
the negative
natural log
of
2x and actually let me make my
color to be the same or as close as i
can so maybe closer to that bluer color
okay and then the next one i want y
is equal
to
two
times
two times the absolute value
actually i don't know whether desmos
prefers i'll use that actually that
works okay
x minus four
and then i will close my absolute value
and then i have minus
seven
and i will do this in the red color
so that we can keep track of things
okay
so those are my two graphs and now i
just need to think about where they
intersect and one of the solutions is x
equal to 0.5 that's not the one they
want they want the other solution so to
speak
so let's see
so let's see we have one solution
actually let me zoom in a little bit
so when x is equal to 0.5 that's this
solution
that's this solution right over here it
looks like
y is equal to zero there but then the
other point of intersection seems to be
right over here and actually desmos has
a nice little feature we'll it'll tell
us that point right over there but you
could even approximate it you can see
that x is over 6 and that each of these
let's see one two three four five each
of those is .2 so it's going to be 6.2
something is what i would do and they
want us to round to the nearest tenth
anyway so you don't even need to use
that feature but you can see very
clearly that when x is equal to
approximately
6.238
that
both that we get a y is equal to
negative 2.54 or another way to think
about it is
when x is approximately equal to when x
is approximately equal to 6.2
that the two sides of this equation are
are going to be equal to each other
approximately equal to each other and
we're done we've just solved using a or
at least approximated solution using
graphing in a graphing calculator